Sie flüchteten als Kinder
ohne Eltern in die Schweiz.
Du hast 50 % Chance zu überleben
und 50 % nicht zu überleben.
Nun müssen sie sich
in einer neuen Welt zurechtfinden.
Ich muss zuerst Deutsch lernen
und so.
Sie wollen ihre Träume verwirklichen.
Als ich ein Kind war, wollte ich
in einem eigenen Hotel arbeiten.
In einem Hotel
oder in einem Restaurant.
Und das will ich immer noch.
Aber nicht immer läuft es rund.
Dachten Sie, das sei locker
und es gehe mit links?
Wie funktioniert Integration
bei minderjährigen Asylsuchenden?
Wie werden sie unterstützt?
Und was wird von ihnen verlangt?
Davon handelt diese Reportage.
Diese Geschichte
beginnt im September 2017.
Acht minderjährige Asylsuchende
bilden eine Schicksalsgemeinschaft
in diesem Haus im Kanton Baselland.
Einer von ihnen ist der
17-jährige Malyar aus Afghanistan.
Vor eineinhalb Jahren
flüchtete er in die Schweiz.
Ich war in meinem Dorf
und dort hatte es Taliban.
Und sie wollten einfach ...
... dass wir mit ihnen
in den Krieg gehen.
Deshalb kam ich hierher.
Wie war die Reise
von Afghanistan hierher?
Die Reise war sehr schwierig.
Wir sind zu Fuss gekommen.
Manchmal war der Weg so gefährlich.
Ich habe
viele tote Menschen gesehen.
Es ist echt gefährlich.
Also, das ist mein Zimmer.
Hier wohnt mein Freund.
Er ist auch aus Afghanistan.
Hier schlafe ich.
Das ist unser Sofa.
Und das hier
ist der Schreibtisch bzw. das Pult.
Ich bin sehr glücklich,
dass ich hier bin.
Gleich nebenan hat ein 16-Jähriger
aus Eritrea sein Zimmer.
Wir nennen ihn Yusef.
Der Sohn eines Bauern flüchtete
als 15-Jähriger in die Schweiz.
Allein.
Er befürchtete, auf unbestimmte Zeit
ins Militär eingezogen zu werden.
Auf der Flucht
hatte ich grosse Angst.
Der Lastwagenfahrer
raste wie wild durch die Wüste,
während wir uns
hinten auf der Ladefläche
kaum festhalten konnten.
Den Schleppern musste ich
umgerechnet 4'000 Fr. bezahlen.
Das Geld gaben mir meine Verwandten.
Eine grosse Gefahr
waren die Leute des IS.
Wenn sie Flüchtlinge aufspüren,
erschiessen sie diese sofort.
Es war sehr schlimm.
Yusef hat noch kaum je
eine Schule besucht.
Marlies Thomann
ist an diesem Tag extra gekommen,
um ihm Nachhilfeunterricht zu geben.
Doch der Eritreer sträubt sich.
Nein, nein, nein, ich kann schon
Deutsch und Arabisch ...
Ja, Arabisch kannst du.
- ... Englisch, Äthiopisch ...
Ich will nicht mehr lernen.
- Aber du warst doch schnuppern.
In der Küche.
- Ja, aber ich will Maurer werden.
Maurer?
Aber wenn du Maurer machen möchtest,
dann musst du
auch gut rechnen können.
Du musst ausrechnen können,
wie viele Steine ...
Für die Maurerarbeit
muss ich richtig essen.
Ja, du musst viel essen.
Es ist harte Arbeit. - Ja, Mann.
Hast du das selber gekocht?
- Nein.
Wer hat es gekocht?
Ich habe einen Dip daraus gemacht.
Du warst doch als Koch schnuppern.
- Er hat es gestohlen.
Er hat es gestohlen? Von wem?
Das gehört Mamal, oder?
- Ja. - Wo ist Mamal?
Ich weiss es nicht.
Ich sage es Mamal.
- Er hat viel Öl gebraucht.
Wie ist der Umgang?
Ist es schwierig mit den Jungs?
Wie sieht es aus?
- Mit mir?
Ich frage Sie, Frau Thomann.
Es ist nicht immer einfach.
Wann kamst du aus Framersheim?
Weisst du das noch?
- Habe ich vergessen.
Im März, letztes Jahr.
August.
- Erst? So Juli/August.
Ja.
Da war es nicht immer einfach.
Da gab es
viele Auseinandersetzungen.
Inwiefern?
Es waren 20, 23 UMAs.
Manchmal waren wir zu zweit
in der Schule.
Es war ziemlich chaotisch.
Okay, tschau, ich gehe.
- Kommst du noch?
Ich habe ...
- Ich wäre bis 16 Uhr hier.
Ich treffe meine Freunde in Basel.
- Ah, okay.
Ja. Tschau.
- Tschau. Nächste Woche?
Okay. Bis nächste Woche.
Die Nachhilfelehrerin
ist vergeblich gekommen.
In diesem Haus in Baselland
telefonieren regelmässig zwei Cousins
mit ihren Eltern in Afghanistan.
* Klingelton *
Hallo?
- Hallo, salam aleikum, Mutter.
Wa aleikum salam.
* Sie spricht Paschto. *
Shezhad ist 18 Jahre alt,
sein Cousin Sheraz 21.
Weil die beiden volljährig sind,
leben sie nicht mehr
in einem Wohnheim,
sondern in einer Sozialwohnung.
Die lebensgefährliche Flucht
im Jahre 2015
hat die jungen Männer
zu harten Kerlen gemacht.
Doch getrennt von Mama zu sein,
fällt ihnen schwer.
Ja, eigentlich
habe ich immer Heimweh.
Aber wenn ich persönlich anrufe
und meine Mutter sehe,
nachdem ich sie
lange nicht gesehen habe,
dann habe ich
wahnsinnig stark Heimweh.
Dann konnte ich nachts
manchmal gar nicht schlafen.
Wenn man mit Mama spricht,
wird man im Herzen ganz ruhig.
Dann fühlt man sich ein bisschen ...
Der Kopf wird ganz ruhig.
Man fühlt sich ganz ruhig.
Und man wird automatisch
etwas glücklicher.
Die Väter sind Goldschmiede.
Für ihre Söhne sahen die Eltern
keine Zukunft in Afghanistan.
Deshalb gaben sie ihnen Geld
und schickten die damals 15-Jährigen
auf die Flucht.
Mit den Problemen in Afghanistan
kann man nicht einfach ...
... ruhig leben.
Die Taliban machen jeden Tag
ein- bis zweimal Scheisse.
Wir haben das
schon ein paarmal selbst gesehen,
dass die Leute kommen und andere
ohne Grund einfach totschiessen.
Die toten Leute
liegen einfach auf dem Boden.
Was habt ihr so alles erlebt
auf dieser Route?
Hat man da viel Elend gesehen?
Elend?
- Hat man viel Trauriges gesehen?
Ja.
- Ja.
Es gab sehr traurige Sachen -
z.B. die Geschichte,
die dir passiert ist:
Mhm.
- Wir waren im Wald.
Ich weiss nicht,
was Shezhad gesagt oder gemacht hat,
aber der Schlepper
hat ihn geschlagen.
Wir konnten nichts machen.
Er hat mich ein paarmal geschlagen.
Wenn man auf diesem Weg ist,
merkt man, dass es 50:50 steht.
Du hast 50 % Chance zu überleben
und 50 % nicht zu überleben.
Von der Fürsorge erhalten die
beiden Cousins monatlich je 450 Fr.
Damit bezahlen sie ihr Essen,
Kleider und Hygieneartikel.
Man muss jeden Tag schauen.
Du hast so viel zu bezahlen.
Hast du genug
für den Rest des Monats?
Man muss immer nachrechnen.
So viel geht für das,
so viel für das.
Sodass du am Schluss was für Essen
und für Rausgehen übrig hast.
Streitet ihr nie zusammen?
- Doch, oft. Oft. - Doch, doch.
Ja?
- Ja.
Fast jeden Tag.
Also, drei-, viermal pro Woche.
Für ein, zwei Stunden
geht es dann nicht mehr.
Weshalb streitet ihr?
- Wegen vielen Dingen.
Wegen kleinen Dingen.
Sheraz und Shezhad sind
vorläufig aufgenommene Flüchtlinge.
Noch ist nicht sicher, ob die beiden
ein definitives Bleiberecht
in der Schweiz erhalten werden.
Im Kanton Baselland
gibt es mehrere Standorte,
in denen minderjährige Asylsuchende
untergebracht werden.
So auch im Erlenhof,
ausserhalb der Gemeinde Reinach.
Zusammen mit einer Sozialarbeiterin
schaut sich Malyar die Zimmer an.
Er möchte umziehen, weil
in der Wohngruppe, in der er lebt,
zu viel geklaut werde.
Hier kochen alle Jungs selber.
Hier kannst du Essen machen.
Und wenn du mehr machst,
kannst du es
in den Kühlschrank reintun.
Hier wird nicht geklaut.
Dann zeigt der Erziehungsassistent
das Zimmer,
in dem Malyar wohnen könnte.
Heute Nachmittag.
- Ja.
Ist das Zimmer zu dritt?
Nein,
entweder alleine oder zu zweit.
Jetzt besteht die Möglichkeit
nicht mehr,
dass du dieses Zimmer
alleine haben könntest.
Es kommt noch ein Jugendlicher.
Daher wärt ihr zu zweit.
Also, warum ich eigentlich
alleine wohnen möchte,
ist wegen der Schule.
Nächstes Jahr ist wichtig für mich.
Es ist die neunte Klasse.
Wir bekommen zwei Zeugnisse usw.
Dafür muss ich lernen.
Und zu zweit an einem Pult
kann ich nicht lernen.
Jetzt brauche ich eine Stunde
zur Schule.
Von hier aus vielleicht mehr.
- Eine Viertelstunde mehr.
Wenn du ein Fahrrad hast,
kannst du bis Reinach Dorf fahren
und von dort
kannst du mit dem Tram weiter.
Mit allem, was du willst,
kannst du zur Schule fahren.
Das sollte kein Problem sein.
Du musst es halt mal ...
- ... ausprobieren.
Du kommst mal hierher
und übernachtest hier.
Dann weisst du Bescheid.
Dann weisst du,
wann du aufstehen musst.
Das Aufstehen ist das Problem.
* Lachen *
Zu langer Schulweg
und kein Einzelzimmer,
um besser lernen zu können.
Malyar möchte doch lieber
am alten Ort bleiben.
Eine Integrationsvorbereitungsklasse
ausschliesslich für Flüchtlinge.
Auch die beiden Cousins
Sheraz und Shezhad
nehmen am zweijährigen Lehrgang teil.
Er soll den beruflichen Einstieg
erleichtern.
Solche Kurse
sind 2015 dringlich geworden.
In jenem Jahr kamen über 2'700 unbe-
gleitete, minderjährige Flüchtlinge
in die Schweiz - mehr als je zuvor.
Inzwischen
sind die Zahlen stark rückläufig.
Im vergangenen Jahr
waren es weniger als 500.
Als Erstes machen Sie das Handy auf.
Jetzt müssen Sie schauen,
wie Sie das aufmachen können.
Sie haben hier Werkzeuge.
Schraubenzieher, Zange, Pinzette.
Nein, alles.
Alles mitnehmen
und dort auseinandernehmen. Hopp.
Sie müssen das Handy aufmachen.
- Mit dem hier?
Mit Gewalt, wenn es sein muss.
- Mit Gewalt?
Ah, okay. - Mit Gewalt.
- Darum haben Sie Zangen.
Ja. Wenn es mit Gewalt geht,
mit Gewalt.
Sie können es ruhig zerstören.
Das wird verschrottet.
Mit Gewalt.
- Uh!
* Er spricht Paschto. *
Der Lehrer will
durch die Aktion sensibilisieren.
In den Handys
befinden sich wertvolle Rohstoffe.
Sie würden unter
ausbeuterischen Bedingungen gewonnen.
Das ist das erste Mal,
dass ich ein iPhone so sehe.
Also, eine iPhone-Batterie.
- Sehen Sie?
Die sind so anders.
Das ist Nokia ...
* Er spricht Paschto. *
Bist du ein guter Schüler?
- Fragen Sie meine Kollegen!
Vielleicht antworten die.
Wie ist er in der Schule?
- Ja, gut.
Er macht immer 5, 5,5 ...
6 auch manchmal.
Er ist ein guter Schüler.
Wolltest du unbedingt Deutsch lernen?
War das wichtig?
Also, nein ...
Als ich in die Schweiz kam,
wusste ich,
dass ich erst Deutsch lernen muss,
weil man in der Schweiz
Deutsch können muss.
War das wichtig für dich?
- Ja.
Als Erstes muss man Deutsch lernen.
Später kommen andere Sachen.
Im Wohnhaus
für minderjährige Flüchtlinge
verbringt Yusef
momentan auch tagsüber viel Zeit.
Der 16-jährige Eritreer darf
vorübergehend nicht mehr zur Schule.
Zuerst schwänzte er regelmässig
den Unterricht.
Den verpassten Schulstoff hätte er in
einem Strafseminar nachholen müssen.
So weit kam es nicht.
Weil er gegenüber Mitschülern
gewalttätig wurde,
schickte man ihn in ein Time-out.
Hast du Probleme?
Nein, ich habe keine Probleme.
Sicher nicht?
- Nein.
Aber du musstest
ein Strafseminar machen.
Ja, weisst du,
ich höre gerade Musik.
Ich höre Musik.
- Nimm doch die Kopfhörer raus!
Hm?
- Nimm doch die Stöpsel raus!
Ah, okay, kein Problem.
Okay.
Easy.
Der 16-Jährige lebt
in seiner eigenen pubertären Welt.
Innere Konflikte überspielt er
mit Coolness. - Hallo, Bro.
Hallo? Ja, ja,
ich bin mit Kollegen am Chillen.
* Sie sprechen durcheinander. *
Komm, komm, komm, komm ...
Komm, wir gehen zusammen
in die Stadt, Kollege.
In der Sekundarschule Reinach ging
Yusef vor seinem Time-out zur Schule.
Wegen seiner Gewaltbereitschaft hatte
man ihn schon mehrmals verwarnt.
Als noch weitere Vorfälle dazukamen,
dispensierte man ihn
für ein paar Wochen vom Unterricht.
Das Fass
brachte Yusef zum Überlaufen,
als er behauptete,
eine Mitschülerin
geschwängert zu haben.
Eine komplett erfundene Geschichte,
sagt sein Lehrer Christoph Gnos.
Vermutlich habe der Eritreer den Ruf
des Mädchens schädigen wollen,
weil sie ihn abwies.
Dass er
in ein Time-out geschickt wurde,
war von der Schule her
eine einmalige Sache.
Man fand,
dass er mit dieser Aussage,
dass das Mädchen
von ihm schwanger sei,
eine Grenze überschritten habe.
Da musste die Schule
ihm auch mal zeigen,
dass es eine Linie gibt:
Bis hierher und nicht weiter.
Für uns an der Schule
war es die Tatsache,
dass das Mädchen
sich extrem schämte,
weil die Aussage
sich schnell verbreitete.
Es wollte nicht mehr
zur Schule kommen.
Dann mussten wir eigentlich
eine Massnahme ergreifen
und haben uns
für ein Time-out entschieden.
Yusef hätte während seines Time-outs
eine Schnupperlehre auf dem Bau
machen können.
Doch schon am ersten Arbeitstag
widersetzte er sich den Vorgaben
seines Chefs.
Daraufhin schickte dieser
den Jugendlichen nach Hause.
In der Wohngruppe zieht sich Yusef
in sein Schneckenhaus zurück.
Du bist anders als sonst.
Ist etwas vorgefallen?
Ja, aber nicht ganz ...
Was?
Gefällt mir nicht ganz heute.
- Hä?
Es gefällt mir nicht heute.
- Es gefällt dir nicht? Warum nicht?
Heute ist einfach nicht,
wie ich will.
Mhm
- Ja.
Reden wir das nächste Mal?
- Ist gut. Kein Problem. Okay.
Patrick Federer
ist der Leiter der Wohngruppe.
Der Sozialpädagoge hat viel Erfahrung
im Umgang
mit minderjährigen Asylsuchenden.
Jugendliche wie Yusef
waren allein auf der Flucht
und durchlebten viele Gefahren.
Das habe sie geprägt, sagt Federer.
Ich denke,
es gibt irgendeine traumatische
Geschichte im Hintergrund.
Also, dass er im Heimatland
schwer traumatisiert wurde -
oder auf der Flucht.
Dass das da so mitschwingt.
Es kann sein, dass er schon eine
Persönlichkeitsstörung mitbringt.
Wir können das nicht feststellen.
Wir müssten eine
psychologische Abklärung machen.
Dann könnten wir wissen,
woran es liegt.
Aber er ...
Er blockiert gewisse Sachen
und dann reagiert er ...
... mit Widerstand oder Abwehr
oder durchaus auch mit Gewalt.
Ich würde sagen,
er versucht, sich zu schützen.
Er versteht etwas nicht
und dann schützt er sich.
Er ist der Meinung,
dass das richtig ist.
Das Schulhaus Ebenrain im basel-
ländischen Sissach im September 2018.
Seit Kurzem macht hier Sheraz,
einer der beiden Cousins,
die Vorlehre
Hauswirtschaftliche Richtung.
Den Integrationsvorbereitungskurs
hat er abgeschlossen.
Frau Picker, was soll ich machen?
Sheraz, Sie dürfen die Suppe kochen.
Das Gemüse ist schon geschnitten.
Die Zwiebeln sind angedünstet.
Das Buch liegt daneben.
Sie können nach dem Rezept
fertig kochen.
Der einjährige Lehrgang
wird v.a. von jungen Frauen besucht.
Sie alle haben
nach der obligatorischen Schulzeit
keine Anschlussmöglichkeit gefunden.
Sheraz ist der erste Mann
in dieser Schule,
der die hauswirtschaftliche Vorlehre
absolviert.
Wie fühlst du dich unter
all den Frauen als einziger Mann?
Am Anfang war es schwierig,
aber mit der Zeit wurde es normal.
Schau mal! So nett!
Sie bringt Wasser und macht das.
Ich sage oft "Schätzeli"
und "Schnucki".
Einfach so. Mir gefallen die Wörter.
Stört Sie das, "Schätzeli"?
Nein, nicht wirklich.
Mich nicht.
Ich weiss nicht,
ob es die anderen ...
... stört.
- Sie hat ein goldenes Herz.
Wissen Sie?
Ein goldenes Herz hat sie.
Komm, jedes Mädchen
ist Fan von einem Star.
Da kann kein Freund etwas sagen.
- Ich bin dein Star, oder?
Man merkt schon,
dass ein Junge in der Klasse ist.
Ja.
- Manchmal gibt es Diskussionen,
bei denen alle Mädchen
zusammenhalten.
Aber nicht so oft.
Wir versuchen, ihn mitzunehmen,
dass er in den Diskussionen
mitreden kann.
Oh mein Gott, wie süss!
Was ist süss?
Das ist so süss wie du.
- (Alle) Ah!
Wie war das? Gut, oder?
Er macht manchmal so Sprüche.
- Ja, oder?
Das war jetzt so einer.
Der Spruch, den er immer macht.
Ich finde, Komplimente sind gratis.
Die soll man geben, weisst du?
Sie sind gratis.
Auch der Cousin von Sheraz
ist einen Schritt weiter.
Shezhad kann in Basel
eine Attestlehre
als Hotellerieangestellter machen.
Stört dich das WC-Putzen nicht?
Diese Arbeit stört mich nicht.
Wenn ich irgendwo arbeite,
gehört all das dazu.
Das finde ich gar nicht so schlimm.
Jugendliche,
die v.a. praktisch begabt sind,
sind für die zweijährige Attestlehre
geeignet.
Hotelfachangestellte Sandra Viera
betreut Shezhad.
Shezhad ist wie mein Sohn.
Ja?
- Ich habe ihn schon adoptiert.
Ja? Weshalb?
Ich finde,
dass er ein toller Junge ist.
Er macht seine Arbeit sehr gut.
Das freut mich.
Er ist so selbstständig.
Und er will nach oben kommen.
Das macht glücklich.
Er wolle das Hotelgeschäft
vollumfänglich kennenlernen,
sagt Shezhad.
Da sehe er seine Zukunft.
Dann machst du mit deinem Cousin
ein Hotel auf?
Vielleicht. Vielleicht.
Wenn du ein Hotel kaufst,
gibst du mir Arbeit, Shezhad.
Ja, du bist dann
die grosse Chefin an der Rezeption.
Okay, ich arbeite mit euch.
Malyar wohnt noch immer
in der Wohngruppe
für minderjährige Asylsuchende.
Er wollte wegziehen, weil ihm
oft das Essen gestohlen wurde.
Einen anderen Platz
fand er noch nicht.
Wichtiger ist für ihn ohnehin,
eine Lehrstelle zu finden.
Was ist dein Traum?
Cricketspieler zu werden?
Nein ... Also, früher schon,
aber jetzt nicht mehr.
Jetzt ist mein Traum,
Informatiker zu werden.
Informatiker.
- Ah, okay.
Aber ja ... Ich gebe mein Bestes.
Malyar ist ein fleissiger
und guter Schüler.
Hausaufgaben zu machen,
ist für ihn selbstverständlich.
Zuverlässig ist er auch
beim Erledigen der Aufgaben
in der Wohngruppe.
Jeder Bewohner
erhält für den Lebensunterhalt
monatlich rund 250 Fr.
Hier ist der neue Kühlschrank.
Das war der alte.
Aus dem
wird das Essen immer geklaut.
Und das ist der neue, kleine.
Einfach für zwei Leute.
Mit Schloss.
Oben sind meine Sachen und unten
die von einem anderen Jungen.
Jetzt wird nicht mehr geklaut?
- Nein.
Bei dem geht das nicht.
Erneut wurde Yusef
in ein Time-out geschickt.
Statt in der Schule zu sein,
arbeitet er nun ein paar Wochen lang
in einer Baufirma.
Du kannst mir das geben.
Jetzt waschen wir die Schublade.
Wir machen das nass.
Dann nehmen wir es raus.
So.
Sein Betreuer lobt den Eritreer:
Er sei pünktlich, ein angenehmer
Zeitgenosse mit grossem Potenzial.
Gesehen?
- Ja.
Wie sehen Sie das Time-out?
- Es ist eine Chance für ihn.
Es ist eine grosse Chance.
Er ist hier 1:1 in einer Umgebung
wie auf dem ersten Arbeitsmarkt.
Er trifft andere Klienten und
hat hoch qualifizierte Vorgesetzte.
Er ist auch im Coach-Setting
sehr gut aufgehoben.
Wenn er es clever macht -
so schätze ich ihn ein -,
packt er das.
Statt in der Schule zu sein,
wollte ich
mit meinen Händen arbeiten.
Ich will hier mein Bestes geben.
Yusef fällt es schwer, über den Grund
seines Time-outs zu sprechen.
Der Jugendliche
missachtete in der Wohngruppe Regeln
und reagierte impulsiv.
Die Sozialpädagogen
sahen sich gezwungen, zu handeln.
Tipptopp!
Das war wirklich
von unserer Seite aus.
Er wollte einen anderen Jugendlichen
der Wohngruppe ...
... angreifen
und er wurde gewalttätig.
Da sagten wir:
"Okay, jetzt ist genug."
Es war ja nicht
die erste Grenzüberschreitung.
Darum entschieden wir,
dass er diese Grenze spüren muss.
Deshalb kam er ins Time-out.
* Sie sprechen Paschto. *
Sheraz und Shezhad
gehen in Basel flanieren.
Seit drei Jahren leben die beiden
Cousins nun schon in der Schweiz.
Wie fühlt ihr euch in der Schweiz?
Gut.
- Gut.
Sehr gut.
- Was ist denn speziell gut?
Es ist einfach sehr schön.
Man kann die Läden anschauen,
es hat so viele Leute,
du kannst überall hingehen,
schauen, probieren und so.
Alles ist gut.
Und man fühlt sich sehr sicher.
* Beschwingte Musik *
Das bunte Stadtleben
dient ihnen bloss als Kulisse.
Mit den Leuten wollen sie in solchen
Momenten nicht in Kontakt kommen.
Wichtiger ist ihnen, die eigene
kulturelle Identität zu spüren.
Es gibt viele Kollegen
in der Schule oder im Betrieb,
mit denen ich manchmal ausgehe.
Aber die meiste Zeit
möchte ich mit Personen,
die meine Muttersprache sprechen,
verbringen.
Ich spreche die ganze Zeit Deutsch.
In der Schule, im Betrieb
und draussen ist alles auf Deutsch.
Dann gibt es diesen Moment,
in dem ich meine Sprache vermisse.
Möchtest du hierbleiben?
- Ja, sicher. Ja.
Ist es für dich Heimat oder nicht?
Nein,
es ist nicht wie unsere Heimat.
Aber für mich
ist die Schweiz im Moment ...
... eine zweite Heimat.
- Die zweite Heimat sozusagen.
Es ist nicht mein Geburtsort.
Ich liebe es hier.
Ich mag das Leben hier.
Hier fühle ich mich sicher.
Es gibt hier viele Möglichkeiten.
Ja, ich ...
Persönlich gefällt es mir sehr.
* Beschwingte Musik *
Yusef hat sein Time-out
im Baugeschäft beendet.
Er sollte nun
wieder in die Schule gehen.
Doch der Eritreer weigert sich.
Darüber sprechen möchte er nicht.
Sein Betreuer Patrick Federer
ist ratlos.
Der Minderjährige
höre auf niemanden mehr und mache,
was er wolle,
sagt der Sozialpädagoge.
Ich würde sagen, er hat Mühe ...
... sich wirklich zu integrieren.
In dem Sinne: Wie funktioniert
unsere Gesellschaft?
Was verlangt unsere Gesellschaft,
damit er hier problemlos mitwohnen
und mitleben kann?
Ich glaube, das ist der Punkt,
wo er aneckt.
Destruktives Verhalten
und mangelnder Integrationswille.
Laut der Koordinationsstelle
für Asylbewerber
trifft das im Baselland auf jeden
dritten minderjährigen Flüchtling zu.
Das ist schwierig für uns.
Das ist der Spagat,
den wir ständig machen müssen:
schauen, inwieweit wir
den Klienten unterstützen,
wo wir ihn unterstützen
und ihm helfen können.
Wo lässt er sich überhaupt helfen?
Wie weit macht die Gesellschaft mit?
Wie lange machen die Schule
und die Behörden mit?
Ja, und schlussendlich:
Wie lange können wir das tragen?
Patrick Federer hat alle Beteiligten
zu einer Krisensitzung eingeladen.
Mit dabei ist auch Lehrer
Christoph Gnos, sowie Yusef.
Er möchte ab diesem Zeitpunkt
nicht mehr gefilmt werden.
Beim Gespräch
dürfen wir nicht dabei sein.
Es endet mit einer Mahnung
an den Eritreer:
Sollte er sich nicht bessern,
würde er
aus der Wohngruppe hinausgeworfen.
Ein paar Monate später,
im Januar 2019.
Die Sozialarbeiterin erzählt uns,
dass Yusef
nicht mehr in der Wohngruppe lebe.
Das Zusammenleben mit ihm wurde
für alle zunehmend zur Belastung.
Als er in seinem Zimmer
beim Drogenkonsum erwischt wurde,
musste er gehen.
Nun lebt der inzwischen 18-Jährige
allein in einer kleinen Wohnung,
bezahlt durch die Fürsorge.
Wenn sie so Schwierigkeiten machen
und sich an gar nichts mehr halten,
keine Tagesstruktur haben
und der Respekt gegenüber
den Betreuungspersonen und anderen
Jugendlichen zu mangeln beginnt,
dann muss man sagen,
dass der Weg halt hier zu Ende ist.
Geht man da nicht das Risiko ein,
dass einer durch alle Maschen fällt
und straffällig wird,
wenn er den geschützten Rahmen
verlassen muss?
Ja, natürlich, das kann es geben.
Das ist ein Risiko.
Das kann man nie kalkulieren.
Das kann auch passieren,
solange sie hier sind.
Ähm ... Leider.
Man kann sie auch nicht
vor allem schützen.
Sie müssen ihre eigenen Erfahrungen
machen.
Sobald sie 18 sind, sind
gewisse Schutzfaktoren einfach weg.
Dann gibt es niemanden mehr,
der versucht,
alles um sie herum zu betten,
damit es für sie angenehm ist.
Inzwischen
hat Yusef dank Unterstützung
eine Lehrstelle als Metallbauer
gefunden.
Damit er die zweijährige Lehrzeit
schaffen kann,
wird er eng begleitet.
Herbst 2018.
Einer der beiden Cousins
macht eine Vorlehre
Hauswirtschaftliche Richtung.
Sheraz hat heute bei Sandra Beer
Unterricht.
Was würden deine Freunde
in Afghanistan sagen,
wenn sie dich bügeln sehen würden?
Vielleicht
würden sie mich auslachen.
Ich weiss es nicht.
Machst du das gerne?
- Ehrlich gesagt, ja.
Es macht mir ... Ja.
Ich finde es sehr schön.
Also, alles, was man für sich selber
machen sollte:
z.B. bügeln.
Das muss nicht
jemand anderes machen.
Das muss nicht eine Frau machen,
wie Sie gesagt haben.
Mir macht es Spass,
das selber zu machen.
Ich finde es nicht schlimm.
Ich finde es nicht schlecht.
Ich weiss nicht. - Nein, ist gut.
Dann können wir es ...
Dann können Sie es ...
... aufhängen. Zu Hause ...
... hängen Sie die Hemden auf Bügel
oder falten Sie sie?
Ich werfe sie einfach hin.
Sie werfen sie hin?
Nach dem Bügeln werfen Sie sie hin?
Also, als Erstes ...
Das Hemd, das ich z.B. anhabe,
bügle ich nie.
Ich wasche es
und ziehe es wieder an. - Jawohl.
Das Arbeitshemd
bügle ich im Betrieb.
Dort hänge ich es auf.
Zu Hause werden T-Shirts, Hosen usw.
einfach hingeworfen.
So, so?
In der Schule und dem Geschäft gut
und zu Hause ...
Genau. Nein, das ist gut.
Danke.
- Tipptopp! Haben Sie gut gemacht.
Aber alles scheint er
während seiner einjährigen Vorlehre
nicht immer gut zu machen.
Schulleiterin Gabriela Ammann
redet dem inzwischen 21-Jährigen
ins Gewissen.
Zweimal waren Sie bei mir verspätet,
einmal bei Frau Picker. - Ja.
Waren Sie heute pünktlich?
- Sogar 20 Minuten früher.
Wunderbar!
Da konnten Sie noch eine rauchen.
Heute, als mein Handy klingelte,
sagte ich mir:
"Sheraz, steh auf!"
"Noch zehn Minuten schlafen
bringt sowieso nichts."
Sehen Sie? Das meine ich.
- "Besseraufstehen."
Wenn Sie sagen: "Sheraz, aufstehen,
ich will das unbedingt."
Je mehr Sie das machen und Ihnen
klar ist, dass Sie das wollen,
dass Sie etwas verändern
und Sie etwas machen ... - Ja.
Und dann aufstehen.
Und Ihre Wörter machen mich ...
Ihre Worte
motivieren mich auch stark.
Das ist gut. Das freut mich.
Es gibt Leute,
wenn die mir etwas sagen,
geht es hier rein und hier raus.
Aber bei Ihnen geht es direkt
in den Kopf, ins Herz, den Körper.
Super!
Gestern sagten Sie: "Sheraz,
Sie müssen pünktlich kommen."
Und heute, als das Handy klingelte,
waren Sie in meinem Kopf.
Wunderbar!
- Dann war fertig.
Der andere Cousin hat eine Krise.
Der 18-jährige Shezhad sagt,
dass ihn die zweijährige Attestlehre
als Hotellerieangestellter
an seine Grenzen bringe.
Im Moment
ist es nicht so einfach für mich
wegen der Lehre, der Schule
und wegen privater Sachen.
Ich muss die ganze Woche arbeiten
und dann in die Schule.
Die Sprache ist sehr schwierig,
die hygienischen Sachen im Hotel ...
Du sagst,
es gebe auch private Sachen.
Was meinst du damit?
Die privaten Sachen sind z.B., dass
meine Familie in Afghanistan ist.
Manchmal höre ich von dort etwas.
Meine Mutter
ist z.B. schon längere Zeit krank.
Das macht mich noch trauriger.
Ich habe dort schon viele Probleme
und dann kommt die Schule dazu.
Manchmal ist es sehr schwierig,
weiterzumachen.
Priska Cavegn Schlumpf
ist die Vorgesetzte von Shezhad.
Er sei ein fleissiger
und beliebter Mitarbeiter,
sagt die Geschäftsführerin
des Hotels.
Er hadert etwas.
Es laufe in der Schule
nicht gut mit dem Deutsch.
Er ist etwas ... Wie soll ich sagen?
Er ist sehr hart mit sich selber.
Er verlangt sich
ein bisschen zu viel ab.
Aber ich denke,
er wird das schon schaffen.
Er ist sehr ehrgeizig.
Er will am liebsten
alles auf einmal.
In den Herbstferien macht Malyar
einen Ausflug ins Berner Oberland.
Freizeitvergnügen
in einem Kletterpark -
das ist für den Afghanen Neuland.
In Afghanistan
haben nicht alle Kinder ein Hobby.
Also, wir spielen schon Cricket,
aber das ist ...
Man spielt nicht wie hier in
einer Mannschaft oder einem Verein.
Man spielt einfach zusammen.
Aber niemand
hat so ein richtiges Hobby.
Ist das wegen der
politischen Situation oder weshalb?
Es ist die Wohnsituation.
Manche Eltern wollen das nicht.
Sie wollen, dass man studiert,
dass man zur Schule geht.
Das finde ich auch gut.
Aber man muss auch ein Hobby haben.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Bald schon
kommt Malyar aus der Schule.
Der 17-Jährige ist fleissig
und schreibt gute Noten.
Gerne würde er
eine Lehre als Informatiker machen.
Es ist sehr schwierig,
eine Lehrstelle zu finden.
Dazu braucht man Deutsch und ...
Und für manche Lehrstellen braucht
man Englisch oder Französisch.
Es ist etwas schwierig.
Mathe geht schon.
Ein angesehenes Hotel
im baselländischen Bubendorf.
Sheraz,
der ältere der beiden Cousins,
absolviert hier den praktischen Teil
der Hauswirtschaftsvorlehre.
Mir macht das unglaublich Spass,
mit Leuten zu arbeiten.
Siehst du deine Zukunft
im Hotelgewerbe, oder weniger?
Als Kind wollte ich immer
ein eigenes Hotel haben
oder in einem Hotel oder Restaurant
arbeiten.
Und das will ich immer noch.
Er und sein Cousin Shezhad
flüchteten 2015 aus Afghanistan.
Die Eltern bezahlten die Schlepper.
Monatelang
waren die beiden Teenager unterwegs.
Sie überquerten Berge zu Fuss,
schwammen durch Flüsse,
versteckten sich in Wäldern.
Ausser Brot und Datteln
hatten sie fast nichts zu essen.
Die Schlepper schlugen sie.
Die Angst begleitete sie tagtäglich.
Sprichst du über deine Geschichte?
Wie du hergekommen bist
und wie es in Afghanistan war?
Nein, nicht oft.
Ganz selten.
Ich will auch nicht jedes Mal
dasselbe repetieren.
Ich will nicht immer
dasselbe erzählen.
Das macht mir auch keinen Spass.
Ich erzähle nicht viel
von meiner Geschichte.
So kleine Geschichten schon,
die mich glücklich machen,
aber was mich traurig macht,
darüber spreche ich nicht.
Wenn man an traurige Sachen denkt,
bleibt man immer traurig.
Denkt man an glückliche Sachen,
bleibt man glücklich.
Ich will nicht traurig bleiben,
ich will glücklich sein.
Es ist ganz wichtig,
die traurigen Sachen zu vergessen,
und von den glücklichen Sachen
zu erzählen.
Im Gegensatz zum Schulunterricht
erscheint Sheraz
stets pünktlich zur Arbeit.
Ich zeige dir,
wie man richtig aufdeckt.
Wir legen zuerst das Messer hin.
- Mhm.
Dann die grosse Gabel.
Und zum Schluss den Dessertlöffel.
Voilà!
Wir sind mit Sheraz sehr zufrieden.
Er ist total aufgestellt
und immer motiviert,
wenn er arbeitet.
Das wirkt sich
auf das ganze Team aus.
Es ist auch enorm toll ...
... wie sie ihn im Team aufnehmen.
Sein einziger Schwachpunkt
ist natürlich die Sprache.
Er ist aber im Lernprozess.
Und in der kurzen Zeit,
die er bei uns ist ...
... konnten wir
schon Fortschritte feststellen.
Es ist enorm schön, das zu sehen.
Malyar feiert zusammen mit
Landsleuten seinen 18. Geburtstag.
Es ist der 1. Januar 2019.
Ob er tatsächlich am ersten Tag des
Jahres geboren wurde, ist fraglich.
Jedenfalls haben
die Schweizer Behörden dieses Datum
in seinen Ausweis für vorläufig auf-
genommene Asylbewerber eingetragen.
Viele Flüchtlinge kommen
ohne Ausweispapiere in die Schweiz.
Kannst du deine Eltern nicht fragen,
wann du Geburtstag hast?
Nein.
- Nicht? - Nein.
Wieso nicht?
- Sie wissen es auch nicht.
Ich bin in einem Dorf geboren
und dort steht ...
Dort schreibt man so etwas
nicht auf.
Nicht?
- Nein.
Ist der Geburtstag in Afghanistan
nicht wichtig?
Bis jetzt habe ich noch nie ...
Ich habe noch nie gesehen,
dass man Geburtstag oder so feiert.
Ich finde, das ist nicht so wichtig.
Als nun Volljähriger
muss er die Wohngruppe für minder-
jährige Asylsuchende bald verlassen.
Zudem wird die Suche nach
einer Lehrstelle immer dringlicher.
Eine Sozialarbeiterin
hilft Malyar dabei.
Ich hoffe so fest mit.
Ich will, dass das gut geht.
Es kommt sicher gut für dich -
egal, welchen Weg es nehmen wird,
ob du ab 2019 eine Lehrstelle
kriegst oder ob du ...
... eine weiterführende Schule
machst.
Aber ich fiebere auch mit.
Es ist mir genauso wichtig wie dir,
dass es gut kommt.
Trotz seiner guten Schulnoten
fand er bisher
keine Lehrstelle als Informatiker.
Nun versucht er es als Automatiker.
Ich habe nur Absagen erhalten.
Sie haben mich gar nicht gesehen.
Sie haben nur geschrieben, ich sei
noch nicht so lange in der Schweiz.
Ich müsse zuerst Deutsch lernen.
"Abschicken".
Schon fertig.
- # Ta-da.
Besser Deutsch lernen
ist auch bei Sheraz ein Thema.
Er braucht Nachhilfeunterricht.
"Der geriebenen Käse
ist für die Spaghetti."
Jetzt haben Sie
einen Buchstaben zu viel.
Es ist "der Käse", Einzahl. Also?
- "Der geriebene Käse ..."
Jawohl.
"Die getrockenen ..."
"... getrockneten ..."
Es ist schwierig.
- Wer hat Deutsch gemacht?
Seine Motivation im schulischen Teil
seiner Hauswirtschaftsvorlehre
hält sich in Grenzen.
Er erscheint zu spät zum Unterricht
oder vergisst die Hausaufgaben.
Er wurde fleissiger,
braucht aber immer wieder Antrieb.
Ich denke, ich bin an der Grenze.
Manchmal mache ich es,
manchmal nicht.
Er macht Fortschritte.
- Ja, besser als früher.
Er braucht aber immer Antrieb.
Mit Anna bin ich zufriedener.
Sie macht es seriöser als Sie,
Sheraz.
Warum machst du es nicht so seriös,
Sheraz?
Manchmal verstehe ich es nicht
und manchmal
habe ich auch keine Zeit.
Und - das sollte man nicht sagen -
manchmal habe ich keinen Bock.
Keinen Bock zu haben
ist kein Argument, das hier zählt.
Sheraz, kann ich Sie
für ein Gespräch haben?
Ja, ich komme.
- Haben Sie Zeit?
Ja.
- Gut.
Schulleiterin Gabriela Ammann
zitiert den Afghanen in ihr Büro.
Wir gehen ins Büro.
So, Sheraz, wir hatten vor ...
... einigen Wochen ein Gespräch.
- Ja.
Ich musste ernsthaft
mit Ihnen sprechen. - Ja.
Weil das mit der Pünktlichkeit
nachgelassen hat ...
... und Ihre Hausaufgaben
nicht kamen.
Ich habe gesagt,
wenn Sie nicht pünktlich da sind ...
... schicke ich Sie nach Hause ...
- Ja.
... rufe den Ausbildner an und mache
eine unentschuldigte Absenz.
Die volle Ladung.
Vom Betrieb lese ich ...
... an sich nur Gutes.
Gute Rückmeldungen für Sie.
Die Herausforderung für Sie
ist wirklich die Schule.
Ja.
Mit der Arbeit im Betrieb
bin ich sehr zufrieden.
Dort habe ich kein Problem.
Aber wenn ich daran denke,
dass am Montag Schule ist,
spüre ich das in meinem Körper.
- Es stresst Sie. - Ja.
Aber wir sind uns einig:
Schule braucht es. - Ja.
Es braucht einen Abschluss,
damit Sie irgendwie weiterkommen.
Das wollen Sie ja auch, oder?
- Ja.
Da müssen wir Sie noch fit machen,
damit Sie das hinbekommen.
Sehr gut!
Dann wünsche ich Ihnen
einen guten Nachmittag.
Ich sehe Sie morgen wieder.
- Jawohl. - Gut.
Sollte sich Sheraz nicht bessern,
droht ihm der Rausschmiss.
So arbeite ich nicht mit ihm.
Ich beschule ihn so nicht mehr.
So geht es einfach nicht.
Es funktioniert einerseits
im System nicht,
andererseits
ist das keine Vorbereitung dafür,
was ich nachher mit ihm machen will.
Funktioniert es hier nicht,
funktioniert es in der Berufsschule
auch nicht.
So, Mann, jetzt geht es los.
Auch bei Cousin Shezhad
läuft es nicht rund.
Nein, nein, nein, nein. Jawohl.
Er hat seine Attestlehre als
Hotellerieangestellter abgebrochen.
Damit steht er nicht alleine da:
Rund die Hälfte aller Flüchtlinge
im Kanton Baselland
brechen Integrations-
oder Attestlehren ab.
Das belegen Erfahrungswerte
der kantonalen Koordinationsstelle
für Asylbewerber.
Der Grund war,
dass ich auf Hotellerie
langsam keine Lust mehr hatte.
Es ging dabei sehr viel ums Putzen.
Am Anfang
machte es mir sehr viel Spass,
aber so langsam ...
Zu Hause putzen,
im Betrieb putzen ...
Das war zu viel für mich.
Dann fand ich, dass ich lieber
etwas mache, das mir Spass macht.
Deshalb habe ich die Lehre
abgebrochen.
Wäre es nicht besser, die Ausbildung
durchzuziehen und fertig zu machen?
Was ich dazu denke,
kommt aus meiner Kindheit.
Ich denke immer:
"Nichts ist besser als ich."
Wenn ich etwas nicht mag,
mache ich das keine Minute lang.
Es macht mich krank.
Und das will ich nicht.
Wenn mir etwas nicht gefällt
oder mir nicht passt,
sage ich einfach: "Stopp!"
Wie es weitergehen soll,
weiss er nicht.
Shezhad ist aber zuversichtlich,
dass er eine Lösung finden wird.
Ein Industriebetrieb in Itingen,
Kanton Baselland.
Malyar kann hier
eine Schnupperlehre machen.
Dann nehmen wir hier
das Viereck weg.
Weder als Informatiker
noch als Automatiker
fand er bisher eine Lehrstelle.
Nun interessiert sich
der Flüchtling aus Afghanistan
für den Polymechaniker-Beruf.
Seit Montag
bin ich jetzt hier am Schnuppern.
Ich habe gesehen,
dass das besser für mich ist,
ein besserer Beruf als andere.
Malyar ist aufmerksam bei der Sache.
Also ...
Hier haben wir unsere Dreh-
und Fräsmaschine.
Programmiert ihr die
mit dem Computer?
Wir programmieren am Computer.
- Okay.
Das kommt
auf unsere virtuelle Maschine.
Habt ihr das gezeichnet?
Also, ein Polymechaniker?
- Ja.
Am Ende der Schnupperzeit wird er
dann noch einen Test machen müssen.
Im Gegensatz zur Schule zeigt Sheraz
im Hotel jeweils vollen Einsatz.
Heute erntet er die Früchte
für seinen Fleiss.
Lehrlingsausbildner Asani Sali
und Hoteldirektor Tamino Palm
haben eine positive Nachricht
für ihn.
Ich finde es ganz toll.
Ich erhalte sehr gutes Feedback
von vielen Gästen,
dass du sehr aufgestellt
und fröhlich seist.
Das ist das,
was bei uns wichtig ist.
Deshalb möchten wir dir
die Möglichkeit geben,
bei uns die Lehre zu machen.
- Merci.
Bitte schön.
Voilà! Ich zeige dir das schnell.
- Ja. - Also ...
Diese Lehre dauert zwei Jahre.
- Ja.
Sie fängt offiziell am 1. August an
und dauert bis am 31. Juli 2021.
Alles gut so weit?
- Ja.
Bist du einverstanden?
- Ja. - Sehr schön.
Einer der beiden Cousins hat nun
also eine Lehrstelle gefunden.
Sheraz wird Restaurationsangestellter
mit eidgenössischem Berufsattest.
Am Anfang dachte ich in der Schule,
ich bekomme keine Lehrstelle,
weil es so schwierig war,
aber endlich habe ich es geschafft.
Vielen Dank an euch alle,
an alle Mitarbeiter und Chefs.
Ihr habt mir mit allem geholfen.
Ich darf hier die Lehre machen ...
Ich bin sehr dankbar.
Danke. Danke vielmals. Merci.
Trotz Lehrvertrag: Das Schuljahr
muss Sheraz noch zu Ende bringen.
Und eine Abschlussprüfung
steht ihm auch noch bevor.
Zum Wohl miteinander.
- Danke.
Super!
Sheraz, alles Gute!
- Vielen Dank!
Willkommen in der Familie.
- Alles Gute. - Danke.
Cheers.
Am letzten Tag seiner Schnupperlehre
muss Malyar einen Test machen.
Lehrlingsausbildner Jürg Friedli
will wissen,
ob der junge Mann für den Beruf
des Polymechanikers geeignet ist.
Wir haben hier zwei Zeichnungen.
Hier hinten sind die Teile.
Sie müssen dann
das entsprechende Teil nehmen ...
... und dann sämtliche Masse,
die auf den Teilen sind,
mit der Schieblehre,
die Sie haben, messen.
Wenn Sie das erste Teil
fertig haben,
mache ich eine Gegenmessung,
um zu sehen,
ob das stimmt,
was Sie gemessen haben. - Okay.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Sehen wir uns das an.
Sie haben als Durchmesser ...
... 10,1 gemessen.
Wenn ich das gegenkontrolliere,
sieht man auf der Anzeige 10,07.
Ja.
- Also ist das absolut korrekt.
Gut, bravo.
Wie lief die Woche?
Was für ein Gefühl haben Sie?
Wie war es?
Für mich ...
Ich finde es war ...
Es ist gut gelaufen.
War es interessant?
- Ja, sehr interessant.
Ja.
Von meiner Seite her kann ich Ihnen
ein sehr gutes Zeugnis ausstellen.
Ich bin sehr zufrieden
mit Ihrer Arbeit.
Sie haben mir gezeigt,
dass der Polymechaniker-Beruf
das Feuer in Ihnen entfacht hat.
Sie wollen diesen Beruf erlernen,
habe ich das Gefühl.
Ich würde Sie sehr gerne
bei uns willkommen heissen
für die Lehre zum Polymechaniker.
Danke. Vielen Dank.
Ich würde mich sehr freuen.
- Ich mich auch.
Malyar wird zusagen.
Ein paar Tage später
unterzeichnen die beiden den Vertrag
für die vierjährige Lehrzeit.
Abschlussprüfung der Vorlehre
Hauswirtschaftliche Richtung.
Jetzt muss Sheraz zeigen,
was er kann.
Frau Picker, ich habe eine Frage.
- Ja?
Kommen die Erbsen und der Mozzarella
zuerst oder später in die Sauce?
Was steht im Rezept?
- Frau Picker?
Wie soll ich das waschen?
Soll ich es Ihnen zeigen?
- Bitte.
Die Stange längs bis ungefähr
in die Mitte aufschneiden.
Dann können Sie
alles schön auswaschen.
Da ist zu viel Milch drin.
Das wird ganz flüssig.
Nehmen Sie Milch raus,
sonst gibt es eine dünne Pampe.
Es braucht mehr Wasser, oder?
Wollen Sie es flüssig?
- Weiss nicht, Sie sind die Chefin.
Die Herdplatte abschalten,
sonst brennt es an.
Das Menü war ihm
schon vor der Prüfung bekannt.
Daheim ausprobiert hat er es nie.
Er hätte den Arbeitszeitplan
zu Hause machen können.
Er kam heute Morgen
und machte ihn dann.
Man könnte sich besser vorbereiten.
Ich bin vorbereitet.
Ich habe alles im Griff.
Aber du
musst immer wieder nachfragen.
Das ist normal.
Manchmal verstehe ich es nicht.
Dann muss ich fragen.
Den Tisch für die Gäste
hat der Asylbewerber bereits gedeckt.
Ich finde den Tisch schön.
- Er ist lebendig und bunt.
Die letzten Wochen habe Sheraz
wieder mehr Einsatz gezeigt,
sagt Schulleiterin Gabriela Ammann.
Er sei pünktlich
zum Unterricht erschienen
und die Hausaufgaben
habe er auch gemacht.
Wie schätzen Sie Sheraz' Zukunft
denn ein?
Er macht seinen Weg.
Auf jeden Fall, ja, ja.
Gerade in den letzten Wochen
hat sich gezeigt, dass es ...
... für ihn nicht so einfach ist.
Auch dieses Pubertäre,
das auch gelebt sein darf,
gelebt sein muss.
Das zeigt sich halt
in gewissen Dingen.
Das ist auch richtig.
Er kommt aber immer wieder zurück.
Man merkt, dass er unbedingt will.
Er gibt sich Mühe.
Er macht das.
Die ersten Gäste treffen ein.
Darunter auch Asani Sali,
der Lehrlingsausbildner von Sheraz.
Der Afghane steht unter Druck:
Sein Essen ist noch nicht fertig.
Ja, jetzt wird es langsam knapp.
- Bei mir ja.
Es sieht schön aus.
- Ja, es sieht schön aus.
Aber wie hebe ich das an?
- Das geht schon.
Nicht ganz einfach, oder?
Aber es geht.
Was soll ich an der Seite machen?
- Sheraz, das müssen Sie planen.
Das ist ein Planungsthema.
Merken Sie,
dass wir immer wieder dazu kommen?
Das müssen Sie sich
im Voraus überlegen.
Warum hast du dich so schlecht
auf diese Prüfung vorbereitet?
Ich weiss es nicht.
Das kann ich nicht beantworten.
Aber es ist ...
Was ist schlimm daran?
Es ist doch alles gut.
Ich bin rechtzeitig fertig.
Trotzdem:
"Das ist nicht gut, das nicht."
Egal, ich kann nicht mehr machen.
Ich glaube, da wurde er
etwas wütend auf sich selber,
weil er sich
nicht besser vorbereitet hat.
Bei den Details zeigt sich das.
Hat das einen Einfluss
auf seine ganze Leistung?
Die Präsentation, die Optik,
macht sicher etwas aus,
aber es ist ja so ein riesiges Feld,
das beurteilt wird,
dass das ein kleiner Teil ist.
Die Oberfläche
haben Sie schön gemacht.
Super! Sehr gut!
Jetzt, da ich Salz
genommen habe, ist es super.
* Sheraz lacht. *
Super. - Danke.
Du hast dir richtig Mühe gegeben.
Für mich hat es auch zu wenig Salz.
Trotz schlechter Vorbereitung
besteht Sheraz die Abschlussprüfung
mit Note 5.
Das Hotel in Bubendorf
hat einen neuen Mitarbeiter.
Shezhad arbeitet wieder
und macht hier ein Praktikum.
Sein Cousin Sheraz
verhalf ihm zum Job.
Als Einstieg muss der Neuling zuerst
einmal das Küchenpersonal bedienen.
Ingie, was willst du?
Wasser?
Und für dich?
Eine Cola.
- Eine Cola.
Ingie hat gesagt Wasser ohne, oder?
Er sagte Cola.
- Hat er Cola gesagt?
Wer hat das Wasser?
Komm, Bruder!
Wasser ohne.
- Danke schön.
Bitte schön.
Als er nicht da war
und ich gearbeitet habe,
fragte ich mich immer, wo er ist,
was er macht und mit wem.
Jetzt ist er bei mir und ich weiss,
was er macht,
wann er arbeitet, wann nicht.
Ich habe mehr Informationen
über ihn.
Wir haben in der Schweiz niemanden,
der auf uns aufpasst.
Wir müssen aufeinander aufpassen.
Es ist irgendwie besser,
wenn ich ihn immer sehe,
im Betrieb, im Ausgang.
Wir sind fast immer zusammen.
Das ist für mich auch besser,
wie er gesagt hat.
Wenn man bei der Arbeit
z.B. mal schlechte Laune hat,
kann ich nicht zu allen hingehen
und das sagen.
Aber ich kann ihm alles erzählen
und sagen, was passiert ist.
Malyar macht einen weiteren Schritt
in Richtung Selbstständigkeit.
Er verlässt die Wohngruppe
und zieht zusammen
mit afghanischen Kollegen in eine WG.
* Lockere Musik *
Zwei Jahre lang
war die Wohngruppe sein Zuhause.
Stets konnte er Sozialarbeiter
um Rat fragen.
Hier wusste ich immer:
"Wenn etwas schwierig ist,
habe ich Leute, die mir helfen."
Aber wenn ich dort ein Problem habe,
muss ich das selber lösen.
Ah!
* Sie sprechen Paschto. *
* Malyar lacht. *
Die Wohnung bezahlt die Gemeinde.
Dank Lehrlingslohn und Sozialhilfe
hat er etwas mehr als 900 Fr. für
den Lebensunterhalt zur Verfügung.
Das ist mein Zimmer.
Das ist das Wohnzimmer.
Wohn- und Besucherzimmer.
In diesem Zimmer hier
wohnt mein Freund.
Das ist sein Zimmer.
Was bedeutet es dir,
so eine Wohnung zu haben?
Ja, also für mich
ist das sehr wichtig.
Es ist ein wichtiger Schritt
in meinem Leben.
Vor fünf Jahren
flüchtete Malyar als Minderjähriger
vor den Taliban in die Schweiz.
Der Afghane musste
traumatische Erlebnisse verarbeiten
und sich hier integrieren.
Nun hat er eine Lehrstelle gefunden
und damit eine Perspektive.
Ich nutze die Chance
diesmal wirklich.
Heute wird Shezhad für seinen Einsatz
während seines Praktikums belohnt.
Du konntest bei uns
ein Praktikum machen.
Wir sind sehr zufrieden.
Darum ...
... machen wir mit dir
einen Vertrag.
Unterschreibst du zuerst?
- Auch er erhält, wie sein Cousin,
einen Lehrvertrag
als Restaurationsangestellter.
Weil Shezhad seine erste Ausbildung
abgebrochen hat,
redet ihm sein Ausbildner
ins Gewissen.
Bleib wirklich dran!
- Das mache ich.
Diese zwei Jahre musst du voll ...
Nicht, dass du wieder abbrichst.
- Das werde ich nicht machen.
Und das meine ich ernst.
Das ist eine tolle Chance für dich.
Ja, und das werde ich schaffen,
inshallah. - Okay.
Das ist für mich eine grosse Chance,
ein grosser Schritt
Richtung Zukunft.
Damit ich auch selbstständig
weiterkommen kann,
möchte ich die Lehre
mit guten Noten abschliessen.
Dann willkommen, Shezhad.
- Danke, Sali.
Wir sind überzeugt,
dass wir das gemeinsam schaffen.
Vielen Dank.
Es freut mich, da weiterzumachen.
Bitte.
Shezhad und sein Cousin
kamen vor fünf Jahren
als minderjährige Asylbewerber
in die Schweiz.
Grüezi miteinander.
Als Flüchtlinge aus Afghanistan
fingen sie weit unten an.
Sie mussten Deutsch lernen und sich
an die hiesige Kultur anpassen.
Es gibt noch ein paar Dinge,
die ich erreichen muss,
aber ich bin auf einem guten Weg.
In zwei bis drei Jahren
haben wir die Bewilligung,
dann können wir
unsere Familie besuchen.
In zwei, drei Jahren
sind wir wie Schweizer.
In der Schweiz glauben sie nun
gefunden zu haben, was ihnen fehlte:
Darf ich Ihnen zum Probieren geben?
- Gerne.
ein Leben mit Zukunft.
SWISS TXT / Access Services
puretype gmbh - 2021